[Musique]
dix ans que cela dure comme chaque année
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines a été le théâtre ce jeudi
premier jour du trophée des entreprises
l'objectif annoncé par les organisateurs
est de tisser des liens entre les
sociétés à travers une compétition
amicale qui se dispute par équipe de
trois
on a vu l'évolution là avec cette
dixième édition on est passé de 20
équipes la première année à 180 et on a
refusé encore une quasiment 25 l'équipe
au moment de la clôture des inscriptions
selon les 540 participants venus de 64
entreprises la compétition arrive à
créer un esprit d'équipé
c'est la société on n'est pas tout seul
si c'est vraiment de la solidarité et
par rapport au travail aussi ça
contribue à former des liens rapprochés
se rapprocher de certaines sociétés
faire connaissance et pourquoi pas venir
collaborer on sait qu'en pour renforcer
encore plus cette cohésion d'équipé un
tracé spécialité conçu au programme une
course à pied du vtt une course
d'orientation
les sportifs ont dû également dompter
les vagues sur une épreuve de radeaux de
500 mètres pour éviter de boire la tasse
les concurrents dû se serrer les coudes
genoux sur l'épreuve de radeau ils
doivent s'organiser ils ont de payet
arado et l'objectif c'est traverser pour
arriver au centre de voile et bien
évidemment pas de finir maintenant la
main au niveau de l'arche d'arrivée au
sein du vélodrome
après l'effort le réconfort tous les
compétiteurs se sont retrouvés après la
course pour partie
un afterwork l'occasion de créer une
nouvelle fois du lien social entre
collègues